bom dia que dia legal em meu nome é
francês kerrouche cima
garanto não sou japonês tá é isso já me
rendeu bastante risada está podem também
é imaginem vocês eu atendo no
consultório de são paulo e os japoneses
ligando pra minha clínica e perguntando
quem está atendendo a todo ano antônio
doutor joão e do xingu hiroshima pode
marcar pra ele né
e aí qual era minha surpresa de quando
eles abriram a porta que entrava aí
rotima nórdico hiroshima sim podem
entrar mas é tão amigo meu que disse que
eu sou o único nordestino japonesa
emitiu mítico hiroshi né mas é eu vim
aqui pra contar uma história pra vocês
que a história do menino que queria ser
saudado e esse menino quando ele era bem
criança toda a vida que se perguntava a
ele o que ele queria ser ele dizia que
queria ser saudado a você quer ser
general não não eu quero ser soldado
ele não sabe explicar porque ele queria
ser saldado ele o ideal e ser saudado
mas não sabia o porquê
e pra quem quer ser saudado o dia mais
importante que tem até o dia 7 de
setembro um tempo parada né
o sonho dele era sair todo paramentado
né com uma farda com aquelas coisas
penduradas não sabe nem o que era
ele chegou de desse manhã compre um a
farda pra mim pra eu sair no dia 7 de
setembro ea mãe comprar e ele espalhou
na escola que ia sair no dia 7 de
setembro paramentado com o soldado né
e aí qual foi a surpresa dele que no dia
27 de setembro todo mundo se perfilam
para desfilar a mãe dele não chegava e
os colegas e cadê você disse que ia sair
todo paramentado e qual foi a surpresa
dele que a mãe errou completamente o que
ele tem pedido né
e naquela época ele foi vítima do que
hoje a gente conhece como o bullying né
só que aí ele teve uma idéia
naquela época ele já desenhava um pouco
melhor do que as crianças da época da
idade dele né
então ele disse eu já sei eu vou começar
a desenhar o que eu quero pra minha mãe
agora é ver se entende por que
verbalmente não funcionou né
e então ele fez o primeiro teste começou
a desenhar e qual foi a surpresa dele
começou a funcionar
ele queria uma bicicleta do jeito que
ele desenhava mãe comprava e aí ele
começou a fazer a mesma coisa ou seja
desenhava ea mãe comprava que ele queria
né
no entanto é um belo dia ele na
brincando na sala da casa dele
ele escutou o pai dele dizer a seguinte
frase meu pai está ficando cego e aí ele
é sentou e disse mas cego que significa
isso né e o padre logo explicou olhe meu
pai vai perder a visão ea uma doença
hereditária chamada glaucoma
naquela época eu não sabia o que era
glaucoma
então fui ao dicionário saber o que era
aquela palavra chamada bié vitória e lá
estava escrito em letras garrafais
hereditário que passa de pai para filho
ferronato
meu avô vai ficar cego
meu pai vai ficar cego eu vou ficar cego
cara isso eu tinha 67 anos de idade
então alguma coisa era eu teria que
fazer alguma coisa como é que eu ia
ganhar dinheiro cega como é que eu ia
continuar desenhando cego não tinha
condições
então tu mal uma atitude para mudar esse
destino
e aí veio uma nova ideia
andando pelo meu interior que eu digo
que é meu porque é dos meus pais a sul
no rio grande do norte terra dos poetas
tá
rio um cego tocando sanfona roupa
vou aprender a tocar sanfona pelo menos
pelo menos quando eu ficar cego eu
tocava sanfona outro prato lá tirou meu
né
e foi assim que eu fiz comecei
autodidata caminho é aprender a tocar
sanfona não também tem um colega meu
quando me ver tocando faz quanto tempo
que você toca sanfona e já faz um bom
tempo feliz porque ainda não aprendeu
mas dá pra ganhar então vamos aprender a
tocar sanfona
no entanto me veio outra dúvida na
cabeça
bem eu vou aprender a tocar sanfona eu
vou ganhar um dinheiro eu vou conseguir
me sustentar
mas se a doença hereditária como eu vou
evitar de passar para minhas filhas eu
vou resolver meu problema
mas minhas filhas como é que eu vou
fazer isso
e foi aí que me veio a idéia
vou fazer medicina vou estudar essa
doença vou curava achar a cura e vôo
abortar a evolução dessa doença maligna
que cega e que só anda pra frente à
visão que você perde não recupera
eu lembro bem na minha infância meu avô
já cego ele eu sentado ao lado dele ele
procurando com a mão um raio de luz e
onde eu peguei na mão dela disse vovô
que só quer e ele disse quero ver o sol
então vou fazer medicina
só que mais uma vez o destino me pregou
uma peça meu pai foi desempregado e eu
tive que sair do colégio
mas mais uma vez não baixamos a cabeça
com 11 anos de idade
eu disse eu já sei o que eu vou fazer
meus pais me tirado colégio eu vou falar
com o irmão diretor do colégio e vou
resolver essa parada e fugiu em uma aula
entrei na sala dele e fui prontamente
retirado pela secretária e ela disse o
que você vai que você quer falar com o
diretor de que só com ele
a curiosidade é coisa particular aqui e
ele viu aquele menino de 11 anos
petulante né
isso quer dizer que é o do irmão meu pai
foi desempregado e eu quero continuar a
estudar
meus amigos ganhou uma bolsa de estudos
da 5ª série primária o pré vestibular a
partir daquele dia minha vida mudou e
então o único compromisso nunca ficar em
recuperação e muito menos ser aprovado
e aí eu consegui terminar meus estudos e
fazer é o vestibular para medicina e
entrar no curso de medicina da ufrn
universidade federal do rio grande do
norte e assim que eu entrei no curso o
logo percebi a minha incapacidade diante
daquela doença chamada glaucoma
fiz a especialidade de oftalmologia
fui para são paulo
dourado fui atrás de tudo e vi que a
doença era muito maior do que eu
imaginava e aquele sonho de criança de
querer evitar a transmissão genética
ficou um pouco para trás mas ao voltar
para a minha cidade eu disse tá mesma
forma algo ainda pode ser feito
e então eu criei uma startup né é uma
empresa que tentava como missão
desenvolver dispositivos que acoplado ao
celular
o défice da diagnóstico e combater a
cegueira
nós fizemos um estudo e escolhemos uma
doença chamada ceratocone
se esse auditório aqui tem mil pessoas
provavelmente duas a três pessoas possam
ter ceratocone aqui porque é uma doença
que acomete 1 para 400 pessoas
é uma doença que ocorre é vai de
formandos eratus significa córnea ícone
seria a forma de cone
o grau começa a avançar chega um ponto
que os óculos não resolvem mais você
passa a usar lentes de contato rígidas e
algumas pessoas em torno de 20 a 40 por
cento vão para transplante ou seja
esperar um doador que faleceu retirar a
cópia desses desse cadáver isso ser
transplantado na pessoa doente
só que essa doença ela onde levar à
cegueira e só para vocês terem uma idéia
no ano de 2011 de tom em torno de 24 mil
transplantes feitos no brasil 14 mil
mais um pouquinho de 14 mil foram de
korn
para vocês terem noção da dimensão dessa
doença
e desses transplantes
o segundo colocado foi o ceratocone
como é que se dá o diagnóstico desta
doença o diagnóstico desta doença se dá
através de um aparelho chamado toll
o topógrafo de córnea para vocês terem
uma idéia o mais barato hoje custa em
torno de 20 mil dólares e o mais caro
100 mil dólares como eu posso combater
uma doença com aparelhos tão caros não
tem condições
são aparelhos caros é sem mobilidade e
que possivelmente nem todas as clínicas
privadas tenham esse aparelho só que se
você der o diagnóstico precoce do
ceratocone
hoje atualmente nós já temos um
tratamento em que você consegue gc essa
doença essa córnea e fazer com que a
doença não evolua então percebam eu
tenho uma doença que leva à cegueira que
causa das sequelas psicológicas que
ciência é mais ou menos na pré
adolescência que dificulta você é
definir a sua profissão porque você é
cometido com a uma deficiência visual
mas se você der o diagnóstico precoce
hoje nós já temos o tratamento eo
diagnóstico precoce só pode ser feito
através de tecnologia mas uma tecnologia
barata e foi aí que aquele menino teve
outra idéia e por que não fazer um
topógrafo para o celular já que todos
vocês aí o celular provavelmente que
vocês têm na mão tem um poder de
processamento talvez maior do que o
computador que levou o homem à lua
então foi vendo isso que nós criamos um
aparelho que acoplado ao celular de
baixíssimo custo ele consegue bater a
foto do olho das crianças e através da
internet e mandar para um especialista
que diga se a criança tenha doença ou
não mas o próprio aparelho ele já podem
dizer se a criança tem ou não tenha
doença
então você imagine você disseminar esses
aparelhos em escolas em que no interior
do nordeste uma professora possa fazer o
dia do combate ao ceratocone e mandar
esses resultados para um hospital
referenciado e nesse hospital
é diferenciado os médicos de poderem
avaliar e dizer olhe só mantém essas
duas crianças que estão sob risco
então vocês podem imaginar o quanto nós
otimizar íamos o serviço público com
essas estratégias
hoje a medicina não podem mais ficar
dentro do consultório hoje dentro do meu
consultório me sinto inútil eu sou mais
um médico mas com a par com os aparelhos
que nós criamos lá nós somos milhões
e aí fomos desenvolvendo outros
aparelhos que estão na nossa bancada é
sempre pensando na parte de prevenção né
além do que eu posso mapear em todo o
brasil e saber onde estão meus doentes
onde eu vou ter que gastar os meus
recursos para combater aquela doença e
não gastar de forma desordenada sem
saber onde estão doentes né
então esse é o aparelho que que nós
desenvolvemos já temos parcerias com
multinacionais mas que infelizmente não
foram para frente por motivos outros né
mas o nosso sonho é que o aparelho possa
chegar em todos os cantos do mundo né e
que isso possa combater a cegueira é que
tanto é nossa' fluence no nosso dia a
dia aqui alguma aplicação do do próprio
aparelho nós ganhamos um prêmio é de
melhor trabalho científico do norte e
nordeste em prevenção à cegueira
também fomos finalistas dentro de vinte
mil trabalhos é no brasil dentro da área
de tecnologia e inovação no combate à
cegueira uma alta sensibilidade e baixo
custo tá certo então é é isso que a
gente tinha pra falar pra vocês e dizer
que aquele menino que queria ser soldado
é continua combatente e vai continuar
combatente até o último dia de vida dele
obrigado